>>> A LANDMARK MOMENT.
A BLACK SUPREME COURT JUSTICE
HAS BEEN SWORN IN TO THE HIGHEST
COURT FOR THE FIRST TIME IN ITS
185-YEAR HISTORY.
>> I WILL FAITHFULLY DISCHARGE
THE DUTIES OF THE OFFICE OF
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE.
>> OF THE OFFICE OF SUPREME
COURT JUSTICE.
>> ACCORDING TO THE BEST OF MY
ABILITY.
>> THAT IS JUSTICE KIRA HARRIS
BOLDEN.
HER APPOINTMENT COMES AT A
SIGNIFICANT TIME FOR MICHIGAN'S
SUPREME COURT.
LAST YEAR THE COURT HAD A NUMBER
OF KEY DECISIONS.
THEY ORDERED AN ABORTION RIGHTS
INITIATIVE TO APPEAR ON THE
NOVEMBER BALLOT, BANNED
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST LGBTQ
PEOPLE AND RULED THAT ONE-PERSON
GRAND JURIES CAN'T ISSUE
INDICTMENTS AGAINST STATE
OFFICIALS.
IT LED TO CHARGES BEING
DISMISSED AGAINST A FORMER
GOVERNOR IN CONNECTION WITH THE
FLINT WATER CRISIS.
THIS TERM THE COURT ALSO HAS A
LOT ON ITS PLATE.
JUSTICE BOLDEN'S APPOINTMENT IS
NOT ONLY HISTORIC, WAIT UNTIL
YOU HEAR HER FAMILY'S LEGACY OF
INJUSTICE IN THE HANDS OF THE
LEGAL SYSTEM.
>> ONE DAY THIS LITTLE GIRL CAME
TO ME AND SAID MS. KYRA, CAN
GIRLS GO TO COLLEGE?
I LOOKED AT HER AND SAID, YES,
I'M A GIRL.
I'M IN COLLEGE.
SHE TURNS TO THE LITTLE GIRL
NEXT TO HER AND SAYS, SEE, I
TOLD YOU.
>> Reporter: LITTLE GIRLS SAW
THEMSELVES IN KYRA HARRIS
BOLDEN.
>> THIS HAS BEEN A LONG JOURNEY
FOR ALL OF US.
>> Reporter: TODAY FOR THE FIRST
TIME THEY CAN LOOK UP AND SEE
WHAT ELSE THEY CAN BE.
>> KYRA WILL BE THE FIRST BLACK
WOMAN EVER TO SERVE ON THE
MICHIGAN SUPREME COURT.
>> Reporter: WITH THAT, HISTORY
WAS MADE AS MICHIGAN GOVERNOR
GRETCHEN WHITMER APPOINTED
BOLDEN TO THE STATE'S HIGHEST
COURT.
>> 185 YEARS WE'VE NEVER HAD AN
AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMAN ON THE
STATE'S HIGHEST COURT.
IT'S ABOUT DAMN TIME.
>> IT'S JUST BEEN AN HONOR, AND
JUST BEEN SO SURREAL TO BE
APPOINTED TO THE HIGHEST COURT
IN THE STATE OF MICHIGAN AND BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR SOME REALLY
IMPORTANT DECISIONS.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK MAKES YOU
TEAR UP?
>> BECAUSE THIS MEANS SO MUCH TO
SO MANY PEOPLE.
>> Reporter: JUSTICE BOLDEN'S
JOURNEY TO THIS COURT, THOUGH,
BEGAN NEARLY A CENTURY AGO WITH
A TRAGEDY.
>> JESSE LEE BONDS, MY GREAT
GRANDFATHER WAS LYNCHED IN
TENNESSEE IN 1939 AFTER ASKING A
STORE OWNER FOR A RECEIPT.
HE WAS BEATEN AND CASTRATED AND
THROWN INTO THE LOCAL RIVER, AND
THE CORONER DEEMED IT AN
ACCIDENTAL DROWNING.
AS A RESULT HIS MURDERERS WALKED
FREE.
>> Reporter: THAT INJUSTICE
DROVE BOLDEN TO LAW SCHOOL.
>> ONCE I REALIZE THAD THAT WAS
SOMETHING THAT HAPPENED IN MY
OWN FAMILY.
>> LESS THAN 100 YEARS AGO.
>> YEAH.
I JUST FEET THE NEED TO BE A
PART OF THE JUSTICE SYSTEM AND
TO GO TO LAW SCHOOL AND FIND MY
WAY IN THAT.
>> IS YOUR GREAT GRANDFATHER'S
LYNCHING THE REASON YOU BELIEVE
YOU BECAME A LAWYER?
>> IT WAS DEFINITELY A LARGE
PART OF IT.
>> SHOW XI WOULD GO ON TO SERVE
TWO TERMS IN THE STATE
LEGISLATURE AND THEN TAKE A
LEAP, A CHANCE AT MAKING
HISTORY.
>> WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE JUSTICES ON OUR MICHIGAN
SUPREME COURT THAT BELIEVE IN
EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER THE LAW.
>> SHE DIDN'T WIN THAT RACE, BUT
WHEN A SEAT ON THE COURT OPENED
UP THIS SUMMER, SHE WAS THE
GOVERNOR'S FIRST CHOICE.
>> THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> HER DAUGHTER EMERSON NOT YET
FIVE MONTHS OLD TOO YOUNG TO
KNOW THE HISTORY HER MOTHER HAS
MADE.
>> EMERSON IN JUST A FEW
GENERATIONS OUR FAMILY HAS GONE
FROM LYNCHING TO LAW SCHOOL,
FROM INJUSTICE TO A CAPITAL J
JUSTICE.
>> FROM INJUSTICE TO CAPITAL J
JUSTICE IS REALLY -- IT'S
AMAZING.
IT'S AMAZING THAT WE CAN MAKE
THIS TYPE OF PROGRESS FOR OUR
FAMILY.
>> WHAT DO YOU SAY TO PEOPLE WHO
LOOK AT THE STATE OF RACISM IN
AMERICA TODAY AND DON'T SEE IT
AS ENOUGH PROGRESS?
>> IT'S NOT.
IT'S NOT ENOUGH.
IT'S ABSOLUTELY UNACCEPTABLE
THAT IN 2022 WE ARE JUST NOW
HAVING THE FIRST BLACK WOMAN ON
THE MICHIGAN SUPREME COURT.
THERE HAS NEVER BEEN A BLACK
WOMAN THAT'S BEEN A GOVERNOR IN
THE UNITED STATES HISTORY,
RIGHT?
IT'S NOT ACCEPTABLE, BUT WE
STILL HAVE TO WORK HARD AND WE
STILL HAVE TO TRY TO BREAK DOWN
THESE BARRIERS.
>> AND 2022, IT TOOK TILL NOW TO
GET THE FIRST BLACK WOMAN ON THE
U.S. SUPREME COURT.
>> YES, YES.
>> WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT JUSTICE
KETANJI BROWN JACKSON JUST A FEW
MONTHS BEFORE YOU, WHAT DO YOU
THINK?
>> I THINK IT'S ONE OF THOSE
MOMENTS WHERE YOU KNOW IT'S
POSSIBLE, RIGHT?
THE SAME WAY THAT PEOPLE HAVE
SAID THAT THEY LOOK AT ME, THE
SAME WAY I LOOK AT HER.
>> REALLY?
>> SHE'S AMAZING, BUT SHE IS A
REPRESENTATION OF WHAT IS
POSSIBLE.
>> ARE WE FIRED UP?
ARE WE READY TO GO?
>> JUSTICE BOLDEN WILL BE UNIQUE
ON THIS COURT, AS THE ONLY
JUSTICE WHO WAS PREVIOUSLY A
STATE LAWMAKER.
>> SO THAT ALSO OPENS THE DOOR
TO OTHER CRITICS WHO SAY, WELL,
YOU'RE A DEMOCRAT, YOU'RE
PARTISAN, YOU SERVED IN THE
LEGISLATURE, YOU RAN AS A
DEMOCRAT.
HOW DO YOU SHED THAT?
>> ALL JUDGES AND JUSTICES HAVE
PERSONAL POINTS OF VIEW.
SO I DON'T THINK I'M DIFFERENT
IN THAT.
MY JOB AS A JUSTICE IS TO
INTERPRET THE LAWS.
>> WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROTECT JUSTICE FOR GENERATIONS
TO COME.
DID YOU KNOW THAT?
>> IN A FITTING FULL CIRCLE,
SHE'LL FILL THE SEAT OF CHIEF
JUSTICE BRIDGET McCORMACK WAS
THE FIRST SHE WORKED ON A DECADE
AGO.
>> THE STATE IS GETTING A SMART,
SAVVY, AND HARD WORKING PUBLIC
SERVANT AS ITS NEWEST JUSTICE.
>> I KNOW THE WEIGHT OF THIS
JOB.
I KNOW WHAT IT MEANS.
IT'S ALWAYS BEEN MY GOAL TO PULL
PEOPLE WITH ME -- VICE PRESIDENT
KAMALA SAID MAYBE THE FIRST, BUT
NOT THE LAST.
THAT'S JUST KIND OF THE MANTRA
THAT I LIVE BY.
>> WHAT AN HONOR TO SIT WITH
HER.
I HAVE TO MENTION ALPHA KAPPA
ALPHA.
WE TALKED SO MUCH ABOUT THE
BARRIERS THAT SHE'S BREAKING
ALONG WITH FOLLOWING THE LIKES
OF VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS,
TONI MORRISON AND SO MANY MORE.
>> THAT PART IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE
BLACK SORORITIES, THE IMPACT
THEY HAVE ON ELECTIONS AROUND
THE COUNTRY, NOT ONLY JUST FOR
WOMEN.
THEY GET PEOPLE -- THEY GET OUT
THE VOTE.
IN LOUISIANA THE LAST
GUBERNATORIAL ELECTION, THE
BLACK SORORITIES REALLY HELPED
IN A RED STATE, PUSHED AND
HELPED TO ELECT A DEMOCRATIC
GOVERNOR THERE.
BUT SHE IS --
>> A FORCE.
34 ONLY.
>> AMAZING.
>> I WANT TO SAY ONE THING.
SHE HAS A 5-MONTH-OLD BABY, SO
SHE RAN THIS CAMPAIGN PREGNANT,
CRISSCROSSING THE STATE.
AS SOMEONE WHO HAS HAD BABIES,
DOING ANY JOB, LET ALONE THAT
JOB IS DIFFICULT.
HER HUSBAND TOOK TWO MONTHS
PATERNITY LEAVE AND WAS AN EQUAL
CAREGIVER AT HOME SO SHE COULD
DO THAT.
WE TALK A LOT ABOUT WHAT IT
TAKES TO LIFT PEOPLE UP.
BIG PART OF THIS FOR HER SHE
SAID AS WELL HAVING THAT EQUAL
PARTNER.
>> I'M NOT SO SURPRISED SHE DID
THIS PREGNANT.
WHAT DID THEY SAY ABOUT GINGER
ROGERS, SHE HAD TO DO EVERYTHING
FRED ASTAIRE DID, BUT BACKWARDS
AND IN HEELS.
WOMEN AMAZINGLY CAN DO THOSE
THINGS.
GUYS, WE'RE NOT THERE YET.
>> A DELIGHT TO SPENT TIME WITH
HER.